hello everyone and welcome to the world
rapid and blitz championship we're first
gonna have the three days of rapid and
then the two days of blitz and uh unlike
uh for all the years uh before this year
we're not gonna have 15 rounds of rapid
we're actually gonna have 13 rounds of
rapid so that's one of the things that
we you guys
need to watch out for when checking out
the games uh and it's going to take
place uh from 26th to 20th december so
over the next three days like i said in
the price fund is hundred and fifty
thousand dollars with the first place
being sixty thousand dollars now this is
a game from uh around three i just got
home uh and i uh well uh decided to show
a game we're starting off with a game uh
magnus played as he's the defending
world champion he's the world champion
in all time formats uh currently
existing except chess 960 uh that still
belongs to wesley so uh so let's uh
check it out and for those of you who
still haven't uh the link is in the
description below not link my email if
you guys want to be a part of this
year's uh just brings people people
together video do send me uh some of
your nice photos or videos where you
teach someone how to play chess uh
we've done i think already three or four
of them may i i i think three of them
but now that being said let's check out
the game uh first of many that we will
cover and of course use hashtag
suggestion to suggest some of the
nicer games that have been played so
magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 uh we have d5 uh knight to f3
knight to f6 and the g3 magnus goes for
the sort of a catalan variation we have
c6 uh and now c4 we have d captures on
c4 and bishop to g2 now this bishop will
be very useful on this diagonal and b5
now for the moment defending the c4 pawn
we have castles by magnus and now bishop
to b7
we have knight to e5 putting pressure on
the c6 pawn even though it's defended
twice uh for the moment but black will
have to develop the knight somehow so e6
we have b3 by magnus challenging this um
uh pawn we have c captures some b3a
captures now getting the semi open a
file for his rook and finally black has
to continue development uh although you
could continue with bishop to e7 but
black decides to go for knight b to d7
it's a known move and it's one that
works out very nicely for black so you
give back the c6 spawn but you will get
some very nice development so knight
captures on c6 uh interestingly the
position has been reached before and
white only tried knight c3 and knight to
d2 but magnus accepts the pawn he plays
knight captures on c6 and the queen to
b6 now putting pressure on the knight
and magnus defends it with d5 so if
black captures magnus will open up the e
file and uh
well we'll try to
somehow attack the black king even
though okay black can just develop the
bishop and castle but that's two moves
and he will be able to save his knight
via knights to a5 so you don't really
have to worry about anything here now
black could capture he could capture
with the pawn he could capture with the
knight he could play bishop to c5 so
many options here black decides to
capture with the knight and magnus goes
knight to a5 now he puts pressure on the
bishop here you can't really do anything
about this so rook to d8 rook to c8 also
interesting it's uh it's also an open
file but uh the queen is on d1 so uh at
least for rapid rook to d8 makes more
sense and now knight captures on b7 not
only capturing the very strong bishop
but also getting that queen to b7 also
very important so queen captures and
knight to c3 now putting pressure on the
knight and basically offering a queen
trade so drev can either
you know just continue developing or uh
trade queens here he decides to trade
queens knight captures on c3 bishop
captures on b7 knight cap for sunday one
rook captures on d1 and bishop to c5 uh
black continues development and if you
look at the position now black is up
upon but magnus has the bishop pair and
it's not going to be easy to defend
those queen side pawns so here bishop to
b2 if magnus wants he can also play
bishop to c6 and try and keep the king
in the center of the board but magnus
says nope you're very welcome to just
castle uh the king might even be
better suited to remain in the center of
the board but uh it's hard to say it's
the bishop pair so maybe king safety
first so here they have castles and rook
a to c1 now magnus fully mobilizes his
pieces
bishop to b4 and now rook to d4
attacking the bishop here and just
knight to c5 going for an all-out trade
with rook captures on b4 rook captures
knight captures on b7 and rook capture
sun b5 magnus wins back his pawn so rook
to d7 and bishop to a3 now magnus
attacks the rook here rook after d8
doubling up on the d file and rook to c6
now
so what do you play here
we have h6 black wants to make some
breeding room for the king so you don't
get
a background checkmated and now rook to
a6 going after the a7 pawn and now
knight to d6 you have to defend this
pawn
but magnus is more than happy to go into
a rook end game so bishop captures on d6
rook captures on d6 now rook captures an
a7 and from magnus being down upon you
can see that black in order to uh really
release some tension uh from the
position had to give up not one but two
pawns and now it's actually magnus who's
up upon but it's a rook and pawn end
game so yeah maybe one pawn is not
enough we have g5 by draft and now rook
beat the b7 putting pressure on the f7
pawn so rook to f8 and now rook to d7
magnus wants to trade off a pair of
rooks and then try and win the rook and
pawn in game rook to b6 we have rook 8
to b7 and here we have a trade captures
captures and now rook the c8 now black
will have to fight off the the pass pawn
and the best way to do this is to put
the rook behind the pass pawn so g4 very
important to move magnus controls the
h5 and f5 squares we have rook to c3 and
now magnus starts pushing his pawn we
have pawn to b4 king to g7 and now king
to g2 we have rook to b3 of course we
have to put the rook behind the pass
pawn and now magnus just starts pushing
his pass pawn king to g6 now comes b6 we
have f5
and the now h3 and now probably best for
black is to just play f4
and then you will always have this very
nice setup here but not only that you
will be able to hide hide your king
behind the uh the e pawn because the one
thing you don't want to allow
is for black white to play some like
rogue b8 we're going to push the pawn to
b7 and then you're going to get checked
by the rook and the white promotes his
pawn to a queen
but instead uh draft played h5 and this
allows magnus a lot more time to
well create something out of this
position so g captures on h5 with check
king captures this would be the mistake
drive was talking about and now rook to
b8 now if the pawn comes to b7 then we
just play rook h8 to check and bring the
queen into the game so black has to go
back with the king king g6 with b7
threatening this check and now king to
g7
uh and okay now you can't
deliver check but you can do something
else magnus starts with e3 we have e5
and now f3 here of course uh you cannot
capture the pawn if you capture the pawn
then we just sacrifice our own rook and
bring a queen into the game with check
so instead we have rook to b1 and now we
have e4 by magnus f captures an e4 f
captures on e4 and rook to b3 cutting
off the white king from entering the
position but now magnus just played king
to f2 and he was in this position on mu
44 that uh alexey drave resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here point is that the king can't really
move if you play king of six of course
we just deliver one check and bring a
queen into the game you can't even play
something like king to f7 that's also a
completely uh losing because just rook
h8 and now if the pawn is captured just
uh check and once the king moves we're
gonna capture this rook so the only
thing you could do is start checking the
white king but of course then we play
king e3 checking the two checking c3 and
now our king goes up the board and picks
up these pawns to give you an example
let's say rogue b6 king c4 rogue b1
black has to uh keep control of the b
file king the d5 attacking the pawn and
now let's say rook b5 check we're going
to play king here king to h7 you have to
play something king f6 and now again the
king has the moves if you go here you
just get checkmated so that doesn't work
you have to move the rook rook b1 and
then we pick up this pawn then we pick
up this pawn and then we are of course
completely winning we will have all the
pawns and the rev knows this and uh
that's why he resigned the game after
king to f2 so there you have it a very
nice game by magnus magnus started with
a win then he got a draw in the second
round and then again a win in the third
round so he goes back to board one after
after three rounds uh we'll see what
happens will he be able to defend his
title as there are many many uh
incredible players here and it's not
going to be easy if you have a game that
you yourself enjoyed and think others
would enjoy to use hashtag suggestion in
the comments or send me an email or you
know use any social media and i will
check it out and hopefully present it uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
marcus busey uh checkmate epilepsy
catherine matriarch uh jack schroeder
and jeffrey redden or for for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day